i
[Música]
ah
el centro nacional de huracanes está muy
pendiente de dos ciclones en el
atlántico la tormenta tropical beta ha
descargado toda su furia en la costa de
texas dejando fuertes inundaciones
los meteorólogos pronostican que las
lluvias se extenderán hasta este
miércoles por suerte la situación no ha
ido a peor ya que el fenómeno tocó
tierra a una velocidad de unos 72
kilómetros por hora se había debilitado
en los últimos días y por eso no fue tan
grave a pesar de que se habían mantenido
las alertas desde port aransas en tejas
hasta morgan city en luisiana el huracán
teddy que los expertos han calificado de
poderoso se mueve hacia eeuu y podría
tocar tierra en algún punto de nueva
escocia aquí en el país norteamericano
se han registrado vientos de más de 130
kilómetros por hora y desde el centro
nacional de huracanes donde se monitorea
minuto a minuto la trayectoria advierten
de fuertes oleajes y corrientes en la
costa este de eeuu y la costa atlántica
de canadá
los meteorólogos ya habían avisado de
que esta sería una temporada muy activa
y que se formarían un gran número de
ciclones sin embargo la ciencia no puede
predecir cuántos huracanes podrían
formarse ni cuál podría ser la magnitud
de los fenómenos por eso piden a la
población estar siempre bien preparados
[Música]
la tormenta tropical beta que este
martes se encontraba ya sobre tierra en
texas eeuu generó sin embargo a su paso
cercano por costas mexicanas distintas
afectaciones por las intensas lluvias en
varios puntos del país en el sureste en
el estado de veracruz hay al menos 2.000
personas afectadas en 33 municipios y se
reportan por lo menos 600 viviendas con
algún tipo de daño mientras que en el
norte de chiapas se derrumbó un cerro y
ocasionó destrozos en un tramo carretero
por otra parte en el océano pacífico la
tormenta tropical lowell al sur de la
península de baja california se combinó
con un canal de baja presión que afecta
desde el noroeste hasta el occidente y
el centro de la republica generando
intensas lluvias en estados como
guerrero michoacán jalisco nayarit y
colima en este último estado se
desbordaron ríos y arroyos en guerrero
las lluvias fueron continuas por más de
48 horas lo que generó inundaciones en
varios puntos del estado y en jalisco en
la zona conurbada de la capital en
municipios como zapopan el agua alcanzó
los 50 centímetros en las calles
y la corriente arrastró varios vehículos
en el país continuará en las fuertes
lluvias ya que si bien
lowell y beta ya no generarán
afectaciones en territorio nacional si
persistirá la presencia de humedad y
canales de baja presión tanto en el
occidente como en el golfo de mexico
[Música]